ce rond point que tout le monde appelle
la place au val a désormais une identité
nicolas sagne a réalisé une sculpture
d'une tonne 7
elle est installée rue maryse bastié ce
sont trois ligas et tout son mari entre
elles normalement elles sont blanches il
faudra lever la lamal âge elles seront
blanches
c'est une sculpture qui parle d' espaces
parce que tu vois ce genre de ce style
d'assemblage on va dire de ligne 2 qui
frappe 21 15 éléments fait c'est l'os et
le travail se masser ma marque de
fabrique
originaire de rodez nicolas sagna fait
le choix il y a un nom d'habiter trappe
suite à une demande du conseil municipal
de la ville l'artiste a conçu cette
pièce en quatre mois avec les
contraintes liées à l'aménagement urbain
si en année la sculpture l'ascum ouvert
en réalité à mettre que là parce qu'à
côté des réseaux des réseaux électriques
des réseaux de gaz des réseaux seul
espace urbain l'aménagement urbain les
belles de la ville qui passe le sou
cette place est à la jonction du
quartier dit de l'aéro stats et de celui
des merisiers l'endroit retenu pour
commémorer la mémoire d'arnaud beltrame
officier supérieur de la gendarmerie qui
s'était volontairement substituer à une
tâche de cours de l' attaque terroriste
de mars 2010 8 à 13
nous voulions rendre hommage à monsieur
beltrame
pour l'ate très presque surhumain qu'il
a accompli finalement de se laisser
assassiner à la place dans une personne
qui n'avait pas les fonctions des
responsabilités qu'il assume et on
pouvait pas laisser passer ça sans en
marquer le souvenir
l'oeuvre de nicolas sanhes mesure 2
mètres 50 par trois mètres l'artiste est
ravie d'animer ce rond point rue maryse
bastié
au printemps je livre in stores à rodez
de naissance et si je les vends et
sculptures mal de coeur sur la même
année donc c'est une très belle année
je suis ravi qu avec montre elle soit
accepter prochainement des bulbes rouge
de tulipes vont être plantés autour de
la sculpture